et direction les états unis à présent au
la zone frontalière avec le mexique
évoque un vif débat
alors que la vice-présidente kamala
harris est accusé de ne pas en faire
assez contre la crise migratoire donald
trump lui se rendra au texas le 30 juin
pour visiter la zone frontalière
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite notre reporter thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
bonsoir thomas après le voyage
diplomatique de la vice-présidente
kamala harris les critiques continuent
de s'abattre sur l'administration
oui et du côté de la maison blanche
on souhaite éviter le terme de crise
migratoire mais la situation est tout de
même assez exceptionnel les services
frontaliers américains ont annoncé avoir
arrêté plus de 180 mille migrants
illégaux au mois de mai c'est un record
depuis le mois d'avril 2000 la gestion
de la frontière est donc devenu un angle
d'attaqué de la part des élus
d'opposition notamment des élus
républicains il faut dire que lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle déjà
joe biden avait fait de ce thème de
l'immigration un combat contre donald
trump qu'il s'était notamment opposé à
la construction d'un mur entre les
etats-unis et le mexique alors face à
ces chiffres
évidemment l'ancien président donald
trump lui s'engouffre dans la brèche
il a annoncé qu'il allait se rendre le
30 juin prochain le long de la frontière
entre les etats-unis et le mexique
l'occasion pour lui de faire un
pied-de-nez à l'administration byden à
qui il est justement reproché de ne pas
se rendre en personne à la frontière
écoutez les explications de donald trump
dans un communiqué on est passé d'une
frontière qui rendait jaloux le monde
entier a une frontière anarchique et qui
fait pitié au monde entier est une
personnalité concentre aujourd'hui les
critiques de l'opposition thomas la
vice-présidente kamala harris mais c'est
à elle que beaucoup reprochent le fait
de ne pas s'être rendu en personne à la
frontière lors notamment de son
déplacement en amérique centrale
il ya deux semaines la question lui
avait d'ailleurs été posée en interview
à la télévision elle avait répondu de
manière sarcastique en expliquant
qu'elle ne s'était pas non plus rendu
en europe alors une réponse qui avait
fait beaucoup de règles et provoqué
beaucoup de réactions à l'époque et
selon certains journalistes même au sein
de la maison blanche on n'a que très peu
apprécié les réponses de la
vice-présidente kamala harris à qui il a
été confié justement de gérer cette
question de l'immigration mais face à
ces difficultés bien aujourd'hui
cinquante six élus républicains à la
chambre des représentants ont envoyé une
lettre à destination du président des
états unis ils y expriment leur
préoccupation quant à l'incapacité
distille de la vice-présidente a géré
cette crise
il demande donc à joe biden de l'écarter
de cette mission écoutez nous avons tous
fait des erreurs dans le recrutement il
nous comprenons quand quelqu'un doit
être remplacé nous vous exhortons
sincèrement à trouver quelqu'un d'autre
dans votre administration pour vous
aider à gérer cette crise à la frontière
enfin concernant ce sujet de
l'immigration il faut aussi parler du
fameux mur on sait que la construction a
été arrêté quelques jours après
l'arrivée au pouvoir de joe biden et
bien on apprend maintenant que le
gouverneur du texas voudrait reprendre
la construction de ce mur avec un
financement de l'état du texas justement
à hauteur de 250 millions de dollars il
ya finalement assez peu de chances que
le projet projet aboutisse puisque la
gestion des frontières américaines
relèvent de l'autorité fédérale et qu'un
état seul ne peut pas s'y substituer
mais on comprend que c'est une manière
pour lui ce gouverneur républicain greg
abbott gouverneur du texas est une
manière pour lui de tacler
l'administration bail de notamment en
vue des prochaines échéances électorales
c'est d'ailleurs ce gouverneur du texas
qui est à l'origine de l'invitation
envoyée à donald trump pour visiter la
frontière à la fin du mois
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington